- [Voiceover] You know what this is.
The wagon, the river, dying of dysentary.
All you ever wanted to do was
get to Willamette Valley safely.
It's the Oregon Trail, but did you know
that this iconic game
started as a board game?
It was 1971, three guys,
Don, Bill, and Paul
were roommates in Minnesota.
They were student teachers.
Don, who would often dress
up as historical figures
to captivate his students,
needed a creative way
to teach lessons about the Oregon Trail.
So he created a board game.
He started by using a map
of the American frontier
and wrote flash cards for
the hardships pioneers faced,
like dysentery, broken wagon
wheels, and snake bites.
As soon as his roommates
got wind of the board game,
they suggested he pump it up by
turning it into a computer game.
Over the next two weeks,
the three men put together
the very first version of Oregon Trail.
But, small problem: they
didn't have a computer,
so they used this wacky
machine, a teletype,
a sort of glorified typewriter
that didn't even have a monitor.
Basically, they would type code
onto these huge pieces of
paper and then print them out.
When the program was done, Don's class
couldn't get enough of the game.
Kids were staying late and arriving early
just so they could play Oregon Trail.
Several years later, Don got a job
with the Minnesota Educational
Computing Consortion,
an educational software company
and he pitched them Oregon
Trail as a program idea.
As soon as Apple 2s were
launched in the late ‘70s
and sent out to classrooms
all over Minnesota,
Oregon Trail became a big hit.
Such a big hit that other
states began licensing the game.
And the rest, as they say, is history.